Hello everybody, Dr. Cutters. This page is dedicated to frequently asked questions. Now understand,
we want to answer your questions when you have them, and not have you just have to search through
and read, listen to all these videos, but they're here. And we also have a video page. We still have our
YouTube video site, but we're not adding videos to that anymore. YouTube is just trying to shut down
anything alternative. So we had to create our own video page, videos at dot, videos dot cutters,
clinic dot com, and there's links to it all over on our website and everything too. So we have several
thousand videos out there. You can search that site too for frequently asked questions that you might
have. That's a good place to search. Search this member site. Search our regular website as well. I
have thousands of blog posts on just about everything you could think of. So I know you have questions,
so I want you to get the questions answered. And that's what our Zoom calls are for, right? So
ask them in the blue box down here on any of these pages. You can send in your question,
and listen to the Zoom call afterward if you can't get on it when we have our Zoom call. So
if you can't get live, you can listen to it afterwards. Still ask the question.
The only say that the only bad question is a question unasked is a good say. I don't mind answering
questions that I've answered a zillion times before, but I do want you to be able to have access to them
not have to wait till Wednesday. Zoom call. So this is really what our ministry is. I feel like God has
given me knowledge, not about everything, but the knowledge that he's given me of one of my purposes
is to be able to teach others. So I used to teach doctors that when I taught seminars to other doctors,
I'd say learn like you have to teach this tomorrow. I don't know where I got that from,
from somebody wiser than me or Holy Spirit gave that to me. Learn like you have to teach it tomorrow
to somebody else. I think that's valuable in every part of life. You're gaining knowledge so that
you could help other people. You're not just gaining knowledge so your head could get bigger.
So that's why whatever I learned something new, I tried to teach it and try to make a video or
something to I'm not going to be around forever. So I want you guys to be able to have this access to
this information forever. So there's all sorts of different questions that you can ask. There's a bunch
on this page answers to those and there's a bunch on our video page and there's a bunch on our website
and there's a bunch on this whole member site. So make best use of it and we just want you to be blessed. We
want you to feel like you're getting answers. We want you to feel like you're getting taken care of
in every step of the way. That's what we're here for. That's what this ministry is all about.
All right, enjoy learning and enjoy growing and to helping others along the way. Do have a
blessed day. Bye-bye.